et on va plus loin avec à mes côtés et
gauthier rybinski bonjour gauthier soir
c'est ont fait peur pour rien il est
toujours facile de jouer la sérénité a
posteriori autant qu'il est prématuré de
tirer quelques conclusions définitives
des déclarations russes mais enfin
vladimir poutine aujourd'hui à enfin
relâché la pression exercée sur le cren
en retirant une partie des troupes
russes massés à la frontière écouter le
voulons-nous du lierre ou pas bien sûr
que non il maintenant c'est pour cela
qu'on a avancé nos propositions pour un
processus de négociation au est
également
c'était aux côtés de la shoah le
chancelier allemand dernier européen a
tenté une médiation entre kiev et moscou
problème l'alliance atlantique n'a pour
le moment pas vu de signe de désescalade
sur le terrain et exprime donc un
optimisme prudent les paroles c'est bien
les actes c'est encore mieux renchérit
jean-yves le drian pour la france
écoutez ministre français des affaires
étrangères j'ai observé
depuis quelques heures
quelques inflexions
à la fois par le mon collègue lavrov et
par venise la défense choïgou à la fois
sur le dialogue à reprendre et sur le
retrait potentiel de certaines unités
militaires
les paroles c'est bien nous attendons
les ath si les actes sont là ce sera
encore
voilà gauthier rybinski peut-on croire
sur parole vladimir poutine alors
écoutez jour pense que vous avez dit en
préambule il est toujours facile après
coup quand on est au milieu du gué de
dire vous voyez j'avais raison bon nous
ici à france 24 on a évoqué un certain
nombre d'hypothèses selon lesquelles
vladimir poutine ne voulais pas
forcément aller jusqu'au bout on est au
milieu du gué comme le dit jean yves le
drian on ne sait pas quel type de
vérification voir aboutir à à conforter
cette idée est-ce qu'on a raison de
faire une confiance aveugle mire poutine
la question est de savoir vous savez
qu'elle est toujours la même vladimir
poutine a des intérêts objectifs ça
c'est clair mais il ya aussi son
irrationalité pas complètement farfelu
de parler de ça le problème c'est que
dans l'irrationnel de vladimir poutine
vous avez aussi bien la volonté éventuel
d'aller jusqu'au bout y compris
militairement
que celle qui consiste à dire toute
victoire symbolique peut être
intéressante pour moi et la victoire
symbolique en l'occurrence face aux à la
dramatisation à laquelle les états unis
ont procédé et les capitales européennes
bien la victoire symbolique dans
l'immédiat peut-être de dire vous voyez
moi je suis raisonnable moi je parle
plus doucement moi je fais procéder au
retrait de mes troupes c'est moi qui ai
la kia la raison qui est la raison avec
lui et non pas ces hystériques
d'occidentaux ça peut faire partie aussi
d'une forme de victoire si on
considérait je m'arrêterai là qu'ensuite
il y à quantité on va dire de régions
plus ou moins disputée et qui pourrait
tailler des croupières à des états comme
l'ukraine comme la géorgie voir la
biélorussie un jour tailler des
croupières à ses états ça voudrait dire
faire en sorte que jamais ces états ne
puisse adhérer à l'otan autrement dit et
je termine cette phase si on a cru et
c'est peut-être une hypothèse que
vladimir poutine en un seul coup
obtiendrait les résultats qu'ils
souhaitent on est peut-être tout
simplement dans la première phase dans
le premier mouvement d'une dune de saint
faustin entre guillemets le mot est mal
choisi mais qui verrait d'autres
mouvements dans lesquels vladimir
poutine considéré que là il atteint au
bout du compte ces objectifs on n'en a
pas fini avec cette affaire ukrainienne
christian makarian il vous a surpris
d'abord vladimir poutine en annonçant
jeudi le retrait d'une partie de ses
troupes est ce qu'on peut parler de
volte face est ce que les occidentaux
ont raison ce soir d'être prudent et
demandé des preuves
je crois qu'on l'a vraiment raison
d'être prudent d'autant plus qu'une
cyber attaques d'ampleur importante a
été lancé contre l'ukraine et contre
certains de l'administration ukrainienne
d'administration centrale au moment même
où les troupes russes avaient annoncé un
retrait on connaît pas le montant de ce
retrait sur l'ampleur on l'a pas trop
d'informations il faut évidemment
attendre mais ça fait partie de la
stratégie de vladimir poutine de garder
toujours la maîtrise et le tempo du
dossier que ce soit en europe ou down
que ce soit vers la tension ou
ouvert la
l'apparentent des escalades il poursuit
son objectif le plus dramatique dans
cette affaire c'est que le système russe
s'est réduit aujourd'hui à une décision
prise par un seul homme il n'y a même
plus un bureau ou un bureau politique
comme à l'époque de l'union soviétique
il n'y a même plus des changes des
courants pas de collégialité n'a pas du
tout de collégialité et c'est l'argent
pour laquelle c'est totalement imprévu
et imprévisible nul ne sait ce que
vladimir poutine en tête comme manoeuvre
mais il s'est sûrement depuis le début
qu'il allait se heurter à exactement à
ce type d'obstacle là alors que va-t-il
faire pour l'instant il ya sûrement une
chose c'est à mon avis la seule qui
n'avait pas tout à fait prévu c'est la
façon dont les américains joe biden ont
réagi et là je pense que les russes ont
été surpris par l'alarmisme des
américains oui l'alarmisme cache pas
seulement des préoccupations de
politique intérieure mais cache aussi
une manoeuvre tactique évidente
militaire c'est que en divulguant
constamment des informations sur l'état
des troupes russes leur degré
d'avancement le moindre mouvement qui
est effectuée les américains envoient
des informations qui dérange les russes
et qui les oblige à le dissimuler à
modifier leur plan puisqu'ils sont
découverts et je ne sais pas si ce
retrait tout frais ne rentre pas dans
une contre manoeuvre russe je resterai
très prudent à ce sujet mais les russes
de toute évidence n'avait pas prévu que
les américains divulgue à ce point d
information et organise des fuites cela
a été démontré organise des fuites qui
se diffuse un monde entier pour gêner
les manoeuvres des troupes russes une
guerre du renseignement qui se traduit
donc par une guerre de communication
gauthier et qui aurait pour conséquence
de contraindre les rues ce retrait est
donc peut-être de générer cette cyber
contre attaque on observe aujourd'hui
sur l'ukraine oui ça n'a jamais été
exclue par par les russes et c'est
d'ailleurs ce que disent ce soir les
services secrets estoniens qui en la
matière connaissent bien ce qu'est la
cyber attaque et qui lisent rien ne
prouve justement qui lie retrait des
troupes russes simplement une accalmie
sur ce front militaire pour se servir un
peu plus du front on va dire
cybernétique et de ce fait là rien n'est
exclu toute la question étant de savoir
pour vladimir poutine comment
déstabiliser le plus possible cet état
ukrainien pour qu'il soit amené à faire
une bêtise pour qu'il y ait d'ailleurs
qui peut être provoquée par des parts
des éléments russe pour qu'il soit amené
à faire une bêtise la quelle bêtise
consisterait vraisemblablement à
s'attaquer à ce qu'on appelle les
russophones du donbass et vous savez que
pour vladimir poutine la défense des
russophones c'est au fond diaries ont
des passeports russes c'est pas un
hasard même ceux qui n'en veulent pas
sentent obligés de les prendre les
passeports russes c'est une façon de
dire d'ailleurs le mot absurde a été
lâché le mot de génocide vladimir
poutine a dit ce qu'on fait au
russophone du dôme bas c'est un génocide
olaf scholz a dit non c'est pas vrai ça
n'est pas ce mot là mais voilà le
prétexte comment il peut être servi
comment il peut être utilisé et de ce
fait la larme cybernétique est un relais
au moment où on veut par exemple montré
une certaine bonne volonté on stoppe où
on commence un retrait à vérifier et de
là on peut utiliser les armes
cybernétiques
le vote aujourd'hui par la douma le
parlement russe d'une demande explicite
à vladimir poutine de reconnaissance de
l'indépendance des territoires
séparatistes de donetsk est lougansk ça
vient accréditer effectivement la thèse
de gauthier rybinski l'idée que vladimir
poutine pourrait demain se servir d'un
argument comme celui d'une menace
immédiat pour des citoyens russes comme
d'une intervention comme ça avait été le
cas en géorgie oui parce que la
manoeuvre est très habile
le président selon la constitution russe
doit promulguer
une loi qui entérine ce que le parlement
a voté si poutine ne l'approuvé pas ça
signifierait qu'il donne tort à la douma
ce qui serait quand même bien surprenant
or dans cet artifice da parente
démocratie qui est le théâtre politique
russe le président bien sûr va se faire
un grand plaisir d'obtempérer et de
promulguer une loi qui soit conforme à
la reconnaissance officielle de donetsk
et et des louanges comme deux oblast de
région de petites républiques autonomes
c'est probablement ce qui se prépare la
seule manière peut-être pour les
ukrainiens et c'est ça le calcul de
poutine d'arrêter ça ce serait de
modifier même à leur tour leur propre
constitution pour concéder une part de
façon fédéral une part d'autonomie à de
nier ce qui à louhansk une quasi
partition une quasi non pas une
partition mais la reconnaissance d'une
sorte de ces sessions organisées mais
c'est là qu'en 2001 vie derrière c'est
la vie c'est l'accord de minsk mais
c'est ce qu'on demande donc poutine est
en train d'essayer à mon avis de mettre
les occidentaux dans l'embarras puisque
nous européens ou les américains doivent
faire pression sur le président
ukrainien et lenski pour qu'il fasse un
geste pour les russes poutine ne peut
pas sortir de cette crise qui l'a
ouverte sans obtenir un petit quelque
chose enfin c'est évident alors est ce
que cette manoeuvre à la douma
déclarer l'indépendance des républiques
de l'obuts louhansk et donesk est
destiné à faire craquer les ukrainiens
ou à convaincre les occidentaux de faire
pression sur les et craignant ou est-ce
que c'est tout simplement pour aller
plus loin plus vite plus fort on va le
savoir très vite encore une fois tout
est entre les mains d'un seul homme à
moscou et c'est ça le plus inquiétant
voyez faire pression sur les ukrainiens
ou en tout cas les impressionner les
intimider ça ne sont pas en prend le
chemin pour l'heure si l'on en juge par
les propos aujourd'hui du chef de la
diplomatie ukrainienne écouter
et
nous nous sommes aussi mis d'accord sur
le fait qu'à par l'ukraine et les pays
membres de l'otan personne n'a son mot à
dire sur la potentielle future adhésion
de l'ukraine à l'otan j'ai pas 4-5-6
revivre pas commencer les bravaches les
des ukrainiens gauthier rybinski il
compte il a pris finalement de cette
crise
n est pas terminée d'une part ce qu'ils
ont appris c'est un certain sang froid
et a joué aussi avec les mots c'est à
dire que le ministre des affaires
étrangères peut très bien dire que
évidemment personne ne dictera à
l'ukraine son comportement ses alliances
sont sa politique internationale mais
que d'une certaine façon si on ne veut
pas voir l'ukraine totalement vassaliser
eh bien il faut admettre un certain
nombre de choses d'où le fait que les
ukrainiens par exemple jusqu'ici est
toujours dit arrêtez de nos états unis
arrêtez de crier à l'alarmisme le plus
total ça nous dessert la dans la
perspective dont on parlait c'est à dire
la reconnaissance de l'indépendance des
républiques du donbass quel serait le
piège et c'est là dessus que les
ukrainiens doivent être socialisé le
piège ça consisterait à faire pour
vladimir poutine une provocation à
l'intérieur de cette reconnaissance
provocation perpétrés par des ukrainiens
et à ce moment-là prétexte pour une
invasion limitée invasion à cette région
de l'est l'invocation quasiment
humanitaire à vocation humanitaire et
vous le savez encore une fois vladimir
poutine parle de génocide à propos de ce
qui fait au russo phone du donbass donc
ça pourrait être ça un texte contre tout
droit international le problème c'est je
rejoins ce que disait christian c'est
qu'à ce moment là les parrains
occidentaux de l'ukraine devront faire
pression pour admettre l'inadmissible
et pour dire attention face à ce que
nous venons ça ce à quoi nous venons
d'échappée c'est bien plus grave que la
sécession du donbass christian en un mot
les européens et encore la fiole
aujourd'hui ils ont su maintenir une
équidistance ou où est ce que
aujourd'hui finalement le cren ne
devient pas un poids d'une certaine
manière occidentaux jouent avec un
logiciel qui a déjà quelques années
celui des accords de minsk et beaucoup
de choses ont changé pour rebondir sur
ce que vient de dire gauthier ce qui a
changé notamment c'est que l'armée
ukrainienne n'est plus celle de 2014 et
qu'elle est en position elle s'est
beaucoup modernisé
d'effectivement donner une correction à
donetsk et à louhansk et d'agréger
potentiellement jallat maire hugues oui
la mélamine craignait s'il n'y avait pas
d'intervention russe serait cette
fois-ci capable de ramener à la raison
de donetsk et les républiques de
autonome de données ce qui est lointain
c'est une des motivations des russes
donc les occidentaux n'ont absolument
rien d'autre à faire que de re ou est
constamment le dialogue avec poutine il
faut pas qu'ils aient un jour sans une
discussion tout en sachant que ça ne
fera pas sur la décision secrète que
prendra au final vladimir poutine dans
la tête de vladimir poutine on m a bien
y être merci christian makarian d'avoir
été avec nous merci gauthier rybinski
pas forcément un peu désagréable parfois
c'était on va loin place aux focus à
présent il ya six mois un jour pour jour
kaboul tombée aux mains des talibans les
américains à quitter l'afghanistan et
depuis est bien d